ومحلية ضخمة وقدرة على توفير
اكثر من ثلاثمائة مليار متر مكعب
اوروبا? عندها ستتخذ موسكو نفس
الموقف العربي قبل اربعين عاما.
مع ثروات العرب هناك ستظهر قوة
الوحدة العربية واي قوة يا سادة
اسرائيلية في الاراضي العربية.
هل تصدقون هذا? بينما تستطيع
ان قررت يوما مقاطعة الغرب حتى
ينفذ ما نطلبه نحن وليس ما
يستطع اتخاذ قرار موحد لمقاطعة
النفط والغاز الروسيين فهل ذلك
الاكثر للنفط والامارات الغنية
نفطيا وقطر ذات الثروة الهائلة
لكن فك العقدة لن يكون الا بايد
عربية. المملكة العربية السعودية
فهي في الحقيقة لحماية مصالح
امريكا. يا لها من قضية معقدة
يريدونه? بالطبع لا. بين القوة
والشتات. في الكويت وقطر والبحر
بين الدب الروسي والقارة لكن ذلك
في الاملاء يا صديقي فقط. اما
اليوم فبين الغرب وروسيا حدود
برية وبحرية وجوية لكن مع
الخليجي فقط للضغط اكثر على
موسكو. فهل حصل الامريكان على ما
من الغاز سنويا. فماذا لو اغلقت
روسيا صنابير النفط والغاز عن
بالمقابل تتفق الامارات والبحرين
مع اسرائيل لنشر دفاعية
استبدال ماضي العرب العريق بحاضر
عنفوان روسيا والقارة الاوروبية
السعودية هي اكبر دولة منتجة
للنفط في منظمة اوبك التي لها
بين العرب ايضا لم تقبل طلب
الامريكان هذا. ومن المعروف ان
امريكي فضلا عن العتاد والسلاح
الذي تمتلئ به القواعد
من الغاز وهي كذلك الجزائر وبقية
الدول العربية بثرواتها ومعادنها
يوما وتكون السعودية والعرب يدا
واحدة لمواجهة الغرب وامريكا
ومجرم للتطبيع فهلا انهيتم هذا
الشتات ايها العرب الدب امام
الدول العربية ان تقارع العالم
بكله وليس اسرائيل فحسب فالدول
باسرائيل. والعراق يجرم التطبيع
والمطبعين مع الكيان الصهيوني.
عندما يتوحد العرب حتما لا شيء
سيقف في طريقهم. اما على ارض
وستأتي اوروبا صاغرة لطلب ود
روسيا. وهناك سيظهر الفرق جليا
العجوز. روسيا تمتلك امكانات
لانتاج الغاز وسوقا عالمية
التي تفرضه على النفط الفنزويلي
وعلى النفط الايراني بعد الرفض
يطلبون ما نريده نحن وليس ما
يريدون كما يقول العرب الغرب لم
والعراق والامارات والسعودية
يتمركز قرابة خمسين الف جندي
ولم تكن هذه المرة الاولى فقد
سبق لهم ان رفضوا الطلبات
قوة العرب اذا اتحدوا واصبحوا
قوة واحدة. هل علمتم ما الذي من
السعودية لم تكن الوحيدة
فالامارات الحليف القوي لامريكا
انتاجها من النفط. ولكن السعودية
رفضت هذا الطلب جملة وتفصيلا.
هذا كله? وما هو الوضع اليوم? هل
لا زال بامكان العرب ان يوقفوا
توقفت السيارات والمصانع
والمعامل الاوروبية جميعها وبشكل
الواقع فالجزائر الدولة العربية
التي ليس لها اي علاقة او صلة
مشتتة بين مطبع مع الكيان
الصهيوني وممتنع دون ايضاح ورافض
الامريكية. تلك القواعد وان كانت
في الظاهر لحماية الدول العربية
دور محوري في تحديد اسعار النفط
عالميا. فهل يعيد التاريخ نفسه
وقالت المملكة نحن لن نكون طرفا
في الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية.
الامريكان نتيجة جيدة امام
موسكو. طلب بايدن السعودية برفع
لكنه لم ينجح? وهناك رأى انه لا
بد من تعاون الخليجيين مع
ولنا ان نتخيل ان الولايات
المتحدة ذهبت لتخفيف العقوبات
بالاقتصاد الروسي للضغط عليها
لايقاف حربها على اوكرانيا
فاتحاد العرب سيشكل قويا لا يقهر
سيرغب الجميع بتجنب مواجهته.
وانهارت اسهم الاسواق الاوروبية
والامريكية بورصة نيويورك وهي
المفاجأة للعالم جاءت من
السعودية اصدر الملك فيصل بيانا
علنيا للعالم اننا سنقطع النفط
عن اي دولة ستدعم اسرائيل يا له
السعودية قطع النفط عن
الامريكان. المملكة التي تمتلك
تحقق لي هالامنية? هكذا قالها
الملك فيصل بعد ان قطع النفط عن
من قرار ارهب العالم ودب الرعب
في قلوب الامريكان هناك طلب
الرئيس الامريكي ريتشارد نيكسون
ارسال مساعدات عاجلة لاسرائيل
دخلت مصر وسوريا في حروب ضد
اسرائيل يومها انضمت الدول
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حاول
الضغط على روسيا بشتى الوسائل
ان بعضهم عدا لركوب الحمير
والخيول عندها ادرك الغرب مدى
اشهر بورصة في فقدت اكثر من مائة
مليار دولار خلال ستة اسابيع فقط
كامل حينها وقف الغربيون في
طوابير طويلة لشراء الوقود حتى
الامريكية المتكررة لرفع الانتاج
من اجل خفض الاسعار والاضرار
صمام النفط الذي يغذي العالم
بالطاقة انتكس الاقتصاد العالمي
العالم كما فعلوها عام ثلاثة
وسبعين? وهل تتخذ روسيا اليوم
موقفا مشابها لذلك الموقف
العربي? هل يعيد التاريخ نفسه?
بقيمة مليارين ومائتي مليون
دولار مباشرة وبدون اي تردد قررت
العمر وعندي امنية. ابغى اصلي
ركعتين بالمسجد الاقصى. تقدر
العربية الى القتال ضد اسرائيل
وعلى رأسها العراق والجزائر لكن
جاء ذليلا متوددا طالبا الرحمة
قائلا ان طائرتي تقف هامدة في
مستعد للدفع بالاسعار الحرة.
لياتي الرد. انا رجال كبيرا في
تظل العجوز بين الماضي والحاضر.
الغرب عندما حاصرت السعودية
الكرة الارضية ايعقل هذا؟ وبينما
المطار بسبب نفاذ الوقود. فهل
يأمر جلالتكم بتموينها وانا